hey guys welcome back to another video
today and if you can already tell by the
title as about 10 minutes ago or about
10 to 20 minutes ago the faction war has
ended season 3 or season 2 is now over
we are now an off season and the samurai
won so congrats to all you samurai GG to
them it's hard fought the Vikings
actually did take round 5 to make the
tiebreaker and the samurai had more war
assets deployed so that's how they got
the win now this is where a lot of
controversy has been stirring up if you
check on reddit at least in the new tab
instead of like the hot tab and the new
tab where all the new posts are there is
I believe like every single post has to
do with the fact that Ubisoft has rigged
the faction or something regarding that
and there's always these screenshots
like this about it's like well the
Knights have 35% deployed war assets and
the samurai don't how did we lose the
tiebreaker like we should have gotten
the win or not
Eric Pope then went on Twitter to
address the situation and he said that
it's during that turn those were the
amount of war assets deployed not in the
entire round so that number that you are
seeing was only for that six hour turn
and not be whole two-week round for it
to count so hopefully that clears up
some controversy between all the
factions and whatnot and then the
rewards weren't even really that great
if you remember last season oh during
season one the one the Vikings won they
did get a ornament you know each new
ornament per character but now Ubisoft
has given us the same ornament for every
single character I'll show you two
screenshots from shinobi and then on
warden of what they look like but
they're really not that great to be
honest I personally don't like this at
all and it's the same ornament for all
14 characters so there's really not much
to you know look at there me being a
knight though I did come in second place
so I will show you what the outline was
for the new the new emblem or shield
outline whatever you want to call it
it's just a silver one but obviously if
you're part of the Viking or the samurai
you can just kind of picture the color
in your head changing you know from like
gold or bronze or whatever you happen to
be ranked at but a couple
people are pointing this out and they're
complaining is that if you look at the
shield
it's the shield outline it's identical
to one of conqueror shields like just
about the same at the same color and
then someone also pointed out that in
season 1 the Viking outline was the same
exact one as warlord shield as like one
of his legendary shield so people are
kind of assuming that Ubisoft doesn't
really care about the faction war and
they're kind of just half-assing their
work because I feel like they could have
made 14 different you know types of
ornaments for each character instead of
having one copy and pasted 14 times so
that's all I really have to say really
quick video though just about the whole
faction work because these things I'm
blowing up on reddit and everyone's
pissed off about one thing thought I'd
clear the air with some things I hope
you all guys did enjoy if you did please
leave a like on this very short video if
you didn't dislike the video that's
completely fine if you're new subscribe
to my channel for the newest four on the
content that I'm always bringing to the
table for all of you guys newest uploads
going to be in the top right we're gonna
we talked about realistic Dominion and
kind of what my opinions were and if the
game really did kind of save it a bit
from this game or if this game would
really did kind of save for honor a bit
also I want to hear your guys opinions
on this on this whole debacle with the
ornaments and is it Rhaegar's and not
rigged I'd love to hear you guys
opinions there's going to be a video
tomorrow for the dev stream Eric Pope
said there's going to be more
interesting news than new heroes so
hopefully he's not trolling us and it's
actually worth it so works have to wait
and see though but new video I'll come
in tomorrow you guys already know that
but I'll see you guys later peace out